oh that's who i am
[Laughter]
and you're like oh all right i'll take
it jennifer coolidge loves a good
impression i would have thought
the actress paid a visit to the tonight
show starring jimmy fallon and couldn't
help but gush over these iconic
impersonations of herself
oh i'm gonna make you a pie dumbass
god
you look like the fourth of july
taking the dog dumbass
come on
ariana grande crushing that it's a great
impression oh yep that's snl's chloe
fineman and ariana grande's spot-on
imitation of jennifer's legally blonde
character paulette
i'm taking the dog
dumbass
and while jen praised the impromptu
impersonations she also credits ari for
helping revive her career i know i sort
of you know
i was going through a dead zone and um
you know
not much was going on and then
ariana did this imitation on your show
and um you encouraged her and um and
then
this ball got rolling
inspired by ari's affection for her work
the legally blonde star reached out to
the singer on instagram and then
next thing you know i was like going to
her house getting fit for a
wardrobe fitting for for thank you next
yeah that was all because of jimmy
fallon and you know yes
well i've only
gone out with one guy that had a big
front tooth
and
i liked it because it
he never got anything stuck in the front
teeth
the thank you next music video gave us
more of the legendary paulette and
hopefully 2022 will bring us something
that we want real bad legally blonde
three we know what's in the works have
you seen a sneak peek of mindy kaling's
script i know it is under lock and key
mindy's working hard on it i know she is
and she's she and i just love each other
we have a great laugh just thinking
about what would l woods be doing right
now this is gonna be just like senior
year except for funner i haven't heard
anything i mean i hear you know every
week i get like a little text or
something going like it's happening or
whatever like and then uh
and then and then i don't hear anything
again reese has a lot going on but um
yeah i hope she
yeah i hope it happens well it's
happening and it seems like we're gonna
get a lot more moments like this bend
and snap
okay um yeah a little less spend a
little more snack visiting characters 20
years later to see what's changed about
them and what hasn't it's a lot of me
and this lady that's all i have to say
legally blonde aside jen is also staying
busy with other gigs she just snagged a
nomination at the 2022 sag awards for
her role in hbo's the white lotus are
you miss mcqueen
quad one syllable
the quad
well two syllables
but the second part is one syllable and
a season two is officially in the works
but the question on everyone's minds all
the fans are like is jennifer coolidge
coming back
only time will tell but jennifer she's
all in they haven't told me what the
script is but i hope i have lots of uh
romance and sex in this next one
you know i felt like i didn't get enough
of that in the first one as one of the
most talked about series of 2021 the
white lotus even has the actress in awe
over its success
it didn't matter where i was this year
i mean it didn't matter that i had a
mask on i could be in a motor boat up in
maine like going by another speed boat
and someone would be like why load i
mean it was it was weird like everyone
saw it everyone saw that thing and um so
that's pretty exciting like it didn't
you know i mean i felt like
um that's the most popular thing i think
i've ever done where people just came
out of the woodwork you know and
and uh like
yeah everyone's so solid that show it's
so exciting